هل من مؤشرات لتغيير في الموقف الالماني
من اوكرانيا ام ان قراءه الموقف باتت اكثر
واقعيه قد يصح الوجهان في الاجابه فحذر
برلين في هذا الملف على المستوى العسكري
لطالما بدا غير مقبول من الحلفاء ولهذا
تعرضت المانيا خلال العام المنصرم لسلسله
من الضغوط بسبب ما يوصف بحكمه برلين
السياسيه
بدايه حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا شكلت منعطفا
تاريخيا في المانيا
فتخلت عن مبدا لا للسلاح الى مناطق النزاع
مبدا تبنته منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وارسلت اولاد
في الاسابيع الاولى للحرب لكن ما ارسلته
بقيه مقتصرا على اسلحه دفاعيه بالكامل
لم تقطع برلين خطها مع موسكو بشكل فجر وهي
التي تعتمد الى حد كبير على الغاز الروسي
موقف اطلق النيترو كما يبدو ليبدا بين
الحين والاخر بالضغط عليها
قبل الحرب باسابيع اضطرا قائد سلاح
البحريه الالماني للاستقاله لقوله انما
يريده الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين هو
الاحترام وان فكره غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا
حماقه سمع الشطر الاول من التصريح حينها
فاستقال الرجل
ومؤخرا استقاله وزيره الدفاع على وقع ضغوط
متزايده تعرضت لها حكومتها لارسال دبابات
الى اوكرانيا
وزيرا جديدا للدفاع
شارك في اجتماع ارمشتاين لدعم اوكرانيا
حيث فشل الناتو في التوافق على صفقه
الدبابات واشنطن لن ترسل برلين لنتورسل
لكن اللوم يصنع فقط متجها نحو المانيا